my mama loved you so much  and she appreciated your love for her  and i'm sorry that she couldn't hang on  until  today your esteem for her  and your regard for her  really penetrated her heart  and it was your affection for her that  did keep her going in these last years  and please come see pop  please do come see him  and while this is so much about the  judge as a duo i want to take a moment  to recognize my sister  a goat you know what that means  so i know that we're talking a lot about  mom tonight as we should be  our beautiful mother  but i want you to know that you also are  being inducted to the hall of fame  tonight  and newspapers don't get much right  these days but when the los angeles  times said you were elvis-like they got  it right  i didn't prepare anything tonight  because i knew  mom would probably talk the most  um  i'm gonna make this fast because my  heart's broken  and  i feel so blessed and it's a very  strange dynamic  to be this broken in this blessed  you